my goal is to simplify complexity you
have those like shower moments or you're
walking at midnight in some town in New
York City and you've got these amazing
brand ideas and and then you start
thinking well I could really start doing
this if only X and if I had this person
or if this technology existed I think
leaders of companies have to consider
themselves editors and you constantly
have to edit the team he's an American
computer programmer and entrepreneur
he's widely known as the co-founder and
CEO of Twitter as well as the founder
and CEO of square he has an estimated
net worth of 1.2 billion dollars he's
Jack Dorsey and here is my take on his
top 10 rules for success rule number one
is my personal favorite and make sure to
stick around although too young for some
special bonus clips and as always if
Jack says something that really
resonates with you make sure to leave in
the comments and put quotes around that
so other people can benefit and be
inspired as well
kind of cliche but just do it a lot of
time is spent thinking about something
oh yeah
talking about it yeah but when you
actually get something down either on
paper or in code or you know in front of
someone that's when things start
happening and you're going to make a lot
of mistakes the important thing is that
you make decisions and you keep moving
forward but you have to get it out there
yeah you have to start and you have to
be brave enough to to take the criticism
may I always go back to the punk
movement in the 70s mm-hmm people would
get out and be on the street thank you
cuz you're a teenager back then yeah and
well and they say what there would be a
there would be learning in front of
people like they get out on the street
and it's the first time with a guitar
yeah and you know they're learning how
to play and they're getting better and
better and better
yeah um and I think that's really
important to just get it down do it just
do it it edit edit it my goal is to
simplify complexity I just want to build
stuff that really simplifies our base
human interaction Twitter was around
communication and visualizing what was
happening in the world in real Times
Square was allowing everyone to accept
the form of payment that people have in
our pocket today which is a credit card
so we've built the simplest way to
accept credit cards and it's just this
little tiny device that we give away for
free and you just download some software
from the App Store and you plug it in to
your mobile phone or your iPad and
suddenly you can take credit cards so if
you're a tax accountant or a lawyer or a
doctor or you know even a hairstylist
you can now accept credit cards it's
really that the users help decide where
we
we are the curators of the technology
and we think we're pretty good at it
mm-hmm but then this leads in my third
lesson is you know you need to listen
you need to be still and really listen
to to what's going on around you
mm-hmm and let that inform and let that
inspire hmm your next steps seems hard
to be still and listen when you've got
your we have 300 follow your following
300 people are you sure ma'am
it's like sure my heart yes I it's
really important that that you're able
to step back and listen to to what's
going on and what patterns emerge so
that you can really consider those and
move them I think I think that's one of
the strongest things you can cultivate
as an entrepreneur is to not rely on
luck but cultivating and the ability to
recognize fortunate situations when
they're occurring mm-hmm
odyo was a very fortunate situation
could have taken that idea not told it
to have not told it to be is not not
told it to know and all my other
co-workers at OU do and tried to start
my own company with with that idea but
the fortunate situation was I was
working with some really amazing people
and we had a great team so of course you
know it makes sense to start there the
fortunate situation for square was that
in 2008 at the end of 2008 the entire
market was crashing down like all of
these abstractions we built upon
abstraction upon abstraction upon
abstraction in the financial world which
no single human understood we're now
falling apart and suddenly we're getting
back to basics back to fundamentals
management teams were being asked to
leave banks were failing you know people
were we're clarifying around like we
need to start getting innovative we need
to start treating our customers so
poorly we need to start insight we need
to stop you know encouraging bad
behavior to reap fees like we need to
really turn this whole thing around and
anytime there's a recession or a
depression that's a great time to
innovate start a company start a project
you know do anything so
you know we recognize we recognize that
time at the same time my co-founder Jim
we you know we contacted me he I've
known him since I was fifteen years old
he was my boss when I was fifteen years
old and he's like Jack I want to talk to
you I want to I want to build an
electronic car company like that's
interesting and he was thinking about it
because the car industry was failing as
well and like he was like why don't we
just give these car companies to well
seasoned entrepreneurs like why don't we
give Ford to Steve Jobs and like you
know that would be amazing
yeah it would be amazing and like you
know GM to Ellison are like what not
he's like and also I want to start an
electronic car company I'm like that's
ambitious but in a moment we decided not
to start an electronic car company but
we wanted to do something together
mm-hmm and we kept having these weekly
conversations about what that thing was
and I was researching a lot with finance
and healthcare because I was looking at
you know doing something in those phases
and Jim called me one day one of us
scheduled me to meetings and he said I
just lost a a glass sale he's an artist
he he sells class and I lost the sale
because I couldn't accept a credit card
and here he was talking on his iPhone
his general-purpose computer and I was
talking about my iPhone I'm like what
your Hertz computer sitting in the palm
of your hand but no way to accept credit
he couldn't accept two thousand dollars
from from someone who wanted to pay him
right like why is that so we decided
that we wanted to answer that question
and we did a bunch of research and I
started writing some server code and we
hired a guy to write some iPhone code
and Jim built some hardware and in a
month we had a little way it was
actually quite a big device that plugged
into the audio jack of your iPhone and
could swipe a card take a payment it
would go through the merchant process
and then generate a receipt with a map
on it and I went around I showed it to a
bunch of investors and they were all
amazed that it could even work so we
decided to really focus on it and make
it a make it a company and
and it really just comes out of like
recognizing that fortunate situation and
recognizing the people around you that
that could help and and just owning it
the biggest thing for me on that on that
path is I need to I need to draw
something out and I need to get it out
of my head I found myself very early on
thinking about something like you know
thinking about this this early idea for
Twitter and saying to myself I could
build this awesome you know you have
those like shower moments or you're
walking at midnight in some town in New
York City and you've got these amazing
brand ideas and and then you start
thinking well I could really start doing
this if only X and if I had this person
or if this technology existed or if this
happened or this happened and what I
what I realize I was doing is I
constantly making excuses for not
working on it and then the window had
passed and then I kind of do anything so
I think it's really really important to
write it out or to draw it out or to
code it but you need to get out of your
head and the reason you have to get it
out of your head is you need to be able
to see it on a surface that is not in
your mind and once you can see it once
you can step back from it then you can
also decide this is you know this passes
my filter passes my you know constraints
so maybe I can show it and share with
some other people and then they'll be
like you know that's the stupidest idea
ever
and or you know that's somewhat
interesting but maybe this and this and
this so the sooner you can do that then
you have a lot of momentum around it and
you can you know really decide if you
want to commit to it and work on it more
or put it on the shelf for a later date
and the realization that I think
everyone needs to have about that latter
option put it on the shelf is that you
can come back to it and it'll it'll
surface back up in another piece of work
or another idea at some point in your
life so you know having that having that
ability to close off a chapter and move
on is really really important you can't
have all these open threads and and
that's what I realized I was doing
and that also encouraged me to to really
write more and to really think about you
know what is what is the story
what do how are people coming to this
and like when I show my friends this how
are they going to react and I would
write it down I would actually treat it
like a play and in and when I realized
that I was writing plays I wrote I read
a lot more place for style and for
substance and for technique and I think
it's you know I think it's I think it's
really good and I think there's another
company that I've always looked towards
for inspiration and I know a number of
people in this room probably have a
similar company in mind which is Apple
Apple I think is run like a theater
company it has a great sense of pacing
has a great sense of story and has a
great sense of execution and it's all
about it's all event-driven it's all
staged driven the stage being a
billboard of the stage being a keynote
or the stage being a product launch all
of it has a very very cohesive end to
end story I mean you think about what
happened when Steve Jobs came back to
the company the first thing he did is he
killed every product line the company
was working on and for two years they
had no product on the market whatsoever
all they had were a bunch of posters all
around the world with Steve's heroes and
I said think different and he was just
focused on bringing up the brand and
making people aware the brand again and
how the brand is aligning to this
particular feeling and story and then
they came out with the iMac and then
built built iTunes and then the iPod and
they realized that wait a minute people
are carrying music on their phones now
so we better build a phone I found and
so this this unfolding of the plot and
the epic story has been very very
interesting to watch especially if you
look back you know to that time when you
came back to the company so I've learned
a lot from that company and other
companies who operate in a similar
fashion constrained is a big thing for
me and this is something that we're
two pair as well hmm it's important to
st. now and it's important to be able to
easily say no and there's many many
things you can do and especially when
you have a successful venture behind you
or you're running with it
it's really important to recognize you
know when where you need to go where
you'd like to go and really constrain
the process and then keep things really
simple in my dispatched days we in 1999
early 2000 we felt something really cool
we loved it and then we hired a CEO that
didn't really match our personalities
and then match our vision and we grew
the company very very quickly and that
really scattered the focus of the
company so what I've learned things I've
learned the Twitter is a you know that
that singular focus that that do one
thing yeah and do very well that works
out I think the biggest thing for me I
think for all startups is that it's
really really easy to
consider any hire as like the length of
the entire company I think I think
leaders of companies have to consider
themselves editors and you constantly
have to edit the team you constantly
have to make sure that you have the best
people in and if there's any negative
attribute within the team person or
element or otherwise you have to part
ways and you get it right away
yeah right away I mean you have to say
like this is the best thing for the
company and to be fair to both of us
like it's just not the right time for
both of us it like any other
relationship need to be able to
recognize what's good and what isn't
isn't optimal and take action on it so
that's that's one thing that you know I
would like with Twitter like we grew
very very slowly and we didn't we didn't
edit the team in the in the best way we
didn't get out of the way of ourselves
often though so that's something I would
never do again what I want to talk to
you about today is a note which I call
daily so if you create a new note in
your notepad or something that you check
on a daily basis this is the most
important thing name it daily and then
write the word do : and then go down a
few lines and write the word don't go on
the one thing I would ask you to do
walking out of this is to every single
day just for a week wake up to this note
check it throughout the day and then
also before you fall asleep check to
make sure that you did and you didn't do
everything so what you put in each one
of these is you have a list of
everything that you want to do every
single day and you have a list of things
that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts is to
notice something that you never want to
do it again you never want to do again
and you just add that to it very very
simple I'm just going to share some of
mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but here we
are number one on my do list is to stay
present I think it's so easy to get
trapped in the past it's so easy to
think about
the future the most important thing is I
stay present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back to this moment number two for me is
be vulnerable show people my mistakes
show people my fears because they can
relate because they're going through
similar things number three
drink only lemon water and red wine
great we red wine is a great modifier
for it this goes with one of my don't
which is don't drink hard liquor or beer
on weekdays
number three is six sets of twenty
squats and push-ups throughout the day I
just have to do them every day six sets
of 30-second planks run for three miles
meditate on this list stand up straight
which whenever I say OEC posture moving
in the audience say hello to everyone
I just bought a heavy bag so I'm
training with a heavy bag so I want to
spend ten minutes with a heavy bag every
day I'm going to do a video journal
every single day and I want to get seven
hours of sleep on my don't list and
again this is one of the hardest things
and a lot of these are personal so I'm
not going to read all of them
well my don't list is don't avoid eye
contact don't be late don't set
expectations for someone and not meet
them don't eat sugar I'm on the Paleo
diet so don't eat wheat lentils or dairy
and then of course don't drink hard
liquor or beer on the way this so this
list while it sounds very very simple
has been fundamental in establishing
patterns for myself and it's something
that I do check every single morning I
check throughout the day and I check
right before I go to bed and I make sure
that I check everything off and go
through it
to our companies I've given it to a
number of students that I've talked to
as we've gone to schools and recruiting
and people have come back to me and said
that this is something that works for me
it's something that's easy to do in
something easy to remember one of the
most fundamental things about it that
I've learned that I've taken away from
it is how it gives you focus how it
gives you something that allows you to
really ignore everything else that's
going on all the other noise to allow
you to focus on what's most important so
this do and don't list for people and
individuals in the company has
translated to a do and don't list for
our company
Foursquare we have a doing don't list we
have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no to for right
now has been fundamental in allowing us
to move fast to continue to innovate and
to really push the boundaries and
continue invent and question and reset
everything that we think about the
organization one of my greatest lessons
that I learned in starting and running
Twitter and starting and running Square
which is how important it is to
instrument all usage you have to
instrument everything for the first two
years of Twitter's life we were flying
blind we had no idea what was going on
with the network we're not no idea what
was going on with the system with how
people were using it we're making
guesses we were basing everything on
intuition instead of having a good
balance between intuition and data and
we were going down all the time because
of it because we could not see what was
happening so the first thing I wrote
Foursquare on the server was an admin
dashboard and we have a very very strong
discipline within the company which is
now 72 people to log everything to
measure everything and to test
everything and we treat the dashboard we
treat the analytics we treat the data as
a product and we call it the inference
team and their job is to instrument all
usage and infer all action and that's
something that we need but it's also
something that our users need
art.when really understood is a province
of every human being it is simply a
question of doing things anything well
it is not an outside extra thing when
the artist is alive in any person
whatever his kind of work may be he
becomes an inventive searching daring
self-expressing creature he becomes
interesting to other people he disturbs
upsets enlightens and he opens ways for
better understanding were those who are
not artists are trying to close the book
he opens it he shows there are still
more pages possible and I think that's
so telling for everything that you all
are about to do all the challenges here
about to face you're going to be the
ones that open the book the world would
stagnate without him and the world would
be beautiful with him for he is
interesting to himself and he is
interesting to others he does not have
to be a painter or a sculptor to be an
artist he can work in any medium he
simply has to find the gain in the work
itself not upside of it one of the
biggest lessons that I've learned
throughout my career is how important
the work is how important not just the
end product is but the actual craft
doing the work inventing within the work
the work of the art student is no light
matter few have the courage and stamina
to see it through you have to make up
your mind to be alone in many ways we
like sympathy as humans and we like to
be in company it is easier than going it
alone but alone one gints gets
acquainted with himself grows up and on
not stopping with the crowd it cost to
do this if you succeed someone you may
have to pay for it as well as enjoy it
for the rest of your life and that's
something if you do something meaningful
you are going to have to pay for it in
all the work but at the same time you
will also be able to enjoy it for the
rest of your life we are not here to do
what has already been done
everyone in this room feels that we are
not here to do what has already been
done know what the old masters did know
how they compose their pictures but do
not fall into the conventions they
established these conventions were right
for them and they are wonderful they
made their language you make yours they
can help you all the past can help you I
think in Silicon Valley and especially
in technology it's so easy to fall in
the footsteps of others to do what they
do because you think it's the right
because the right way because you think
you've they've had the success and you
can copy that success you have to find
your own path you have to find your own
footsteps an arts student must be a
master from the beginning that is he
must be the master of such as he has by
being now master of such as he has
there's promise that he will be a master
in the future and what I mean what he
means by this is purely you have to be a
master of your own tools that master
ship is not is not a destination it is a
process and it's constant practice that
gets you there it is not enough to have
thought great things before doing the
work we have so many ideas but what
really matters is the work to implement
those ideas now don't worry about the
rejections every beat everybody that
that's good has gone through it don't
let it matter if your works are not
accepted at once the better or more
personal you are the less likely they
are of acceptance just remember that the
object of painting pictures is not
simply to get them in exhibition it is
all very fine to have your pictures hung
but you are painting for yourself not
for the jury and what's meaningful about
this passage to me is we work so hard to
get some sort of acceptance in the world
to get some sort of positive feedback
and we look at others and it seemed so
fast their success it seems like they
did it in just a moment but it takes
years and
years and years and patients bookmarking
interface is not easy amis there's a
time and place for all things the
difficulty is to use them only in their
proper time and place there's a time and
place for all things the difficulty is
to use them only in the proper time in
place with motive if you will become
clairvoyant of means you will cease and
command them without motive you will
wobble about this in building a team and
building an organization building
company is one of the greatest lessons
you cannot do anything without a shared
and common sense of purpose if you don't
have motive if you don't have purpose
that are shared between everyone you
will wander about you will wobble and
you will not do anything of infinite
means you will not do anything that is
timeless and lastly the art-student
of these days is a pioneer just like all
of you they are student of today must
pioneer beyond the mere matters of fact
I believe the great artists of the
future will use fewer words copy fewer
things essays will be shorter in words
and longer in meaning I love this
passage I believe the great artists of
the future will use fewer words copy
fewer things essays will be shorter in
words and longer in meaning we must
paint only what is important to us must
not respond to outside demands they do
not know what they want or what we have
to give I think one of the most
important things about what you all of
you do is that you are building what you
want to see in the world you're making
that bet that other people want to see
the same thing in the world sometimes
you lose a bet sometimes you win the bet
but the most important thing is you have
that passion to build for yourself
because that is what's infectious and
that is what brings other people to your
cause and
your team
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this video I made it
because dig VGA asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
have been a profound next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know what the jacks say
that really inspired you that motivated
you that made you think or question
something leave in the comments and I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and I'll
see you soon
how do you go about attracting funding
and then managing your investors after
you've secured it I think the that the
thing that's always worked for me is
realizing that your your investors are
first and foremost I always want to go
to anyone that I want to work with with
something to show and it was really
important to us before we talk to any
investors on the Twitter side that we
actually had people using the service
and in in in some at some scale and on
the square side that we actually had a
working prototype square we had really
seven merchants when we actually went to
raise money but we had a working
prototype that people were actually
using and if people can't see it and
feel it's very very hard to sell and I
don't want to just go and tell people
this can be the biggest thing ever I
want to I want to be able to show that
and have them feel it and walk away
feeling that as well so that's first and
foremost is have something to show and
so that they can actually feel and start
making it a part of their story as well
and feel like they have ownership over
it and then second is a realization like
I always kind of approach this is like
this is a this is a if we take money
from someone this is kind of like hiring
someone that we can never fire we can
never get rid of right so that means do
we really want to work with this person
is this person going to be someone that
really pushes us pushes us in the way
that we need to be pushed and and you
can tell that very fairly quickly in
that first week of pitching square got a
lot of people who said you know ok great
we don't have any questions we'll get
back to you in about 30 minutes probably
with with the term sheet and I said I
don't want a term sheet especially if
you're not asking any questions because
they ask no questions during doing the
pitch and that means if if they're on
our board that they're actually not
going to be all that constructive in
terms of really asking the tough
questions and making sure that we're you
know we're not just in our own bubble
but they're looking outside that is the
role of the board is to
to look outside and bring all their
insight and wisdom to us so that we can
help guide the guide the company and in
that second week we got a lot of tough
questions and that's what I love because
I know if I'm getting tough questions in
the pitch I'm going to get tough
questions in the boardroom as well and
not just the boardroom but every week I
mean if a node emails me once a week
about have you thought about this are
you doing this and you know I know this
person can I make an introduction here
and it's just very very useful so I'm
looking for someone who I just love
working with and I think you you have to
set a very very high bar it's not just
about money or the firm it's about the
individual that you're ultimately going
to work with and people ask me all the
time like you know what firms would
would you suggest I go pitch and like
find find the people that you really
want to work with in those firms and if
there's someone that really you know
just really resonates with you and you
love and you love the idea of working
with them focus on them and if it if it
tests out to be to be the case great but
I think you have to kind of treat it as
like I'm adding this person to my team
one of the biggest things that has
helped me is learning how to become a
better storyteller and the power of a
story and by this I mean if you want to
build a product and you want to build a
product that is relevant to folks you
need to put yourself in their shoes and
you need to write a story from their
side
so we spend a lot of time writing what's
called user narratives of this user or
this person is in the middle of Chicago
and they go to a coffee store in the
middle of Chicago and this is the
experience they're going to have it
reads like a play it's really it's
really really beautiful and if you do
that story well then all of the
prioritization all of the product all of
the design and all the coordination that
you need
to do with these products just falls out
naturally because you can edit the story
and everyone everyone can relate to the
story from all levels of the
organization engineers to operations to
support to designers to you know the
business the business side of the house
so that story is very very important for
us and really constantly considering the
story and what new twist and elements we
need to add this story are a pretty big
deal for us as well and we want to tell
an epic story we want to solve a really
big problem we don't want to have a
bunch of short stories strung together
we want one epic cohesive story that we
tell the world and both both Twitter and
square are driving driving towards this
goal it's a number two good storytelling
and writing stories for for the users
who's your favorite CEO entrepreneur
that you would like to be a role model I
always look up to uh Steve Jobs hi
I know I know it's a common one but I
think that's for a reason and I think
he's done some some amazing things he
has is a great pacing okay mm-hmm you
know there are a lot of horror stories
mm-hmm he is a very opinionated person
mm-hmm but he has a direction and he
knows what he wants to do
and he doesn't yeah and he makes sure
that when you know he's not so good an
area he recognizes it and he fills that
area mm-hmm and that's really important
for any to do I think is to really
recognize your weaknesses and and bring
amazing people and bring people in that
are much smarter and smarter than you
yeah you know just create a creative
work environment